Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm... Fuwa.
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 39th episode!
That means...
Almost 40.
Almost 40 episodes already, Ruffians!
I don't know how this happened.
It's very strange.
Well, I can see maybe a few Ruffians who might be joining us for the first time today, but FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Huh?
Lots of bouncing.
Bouncing in the morning.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Moco-chan.
Guess what?
It's a new month.
I don't know.
Pero maybe is going somewhere warm?
Let's see another Ruffian's eyes.
Today's Pero Sighting is... De-den.
Is it warm?
Desert!
Oh my goodness, the desert!
Is it?
Wait, is it that warm though?
You went for a walk in the desert and saw Pero there?
No, forget Pero!
A desert.
It must have been sort of hot and scary.
Although it looks sort of, sort of hot.
It looks cloudy, maybe it wasn't that hot.
Definitely scary.
I don't know.
There aren't any deserts in the Northwest Passage, so it's pretty different.
It sort of looks like a movie set, right?
And a camel?
What?
A camel?
Camels are scary.
Why did you go to the desert though?
I guess it's a question we could ask Pero too, but... Well, I think if I was to go to the desert, maybe I would want to go eat the rare cactuses.
Are you sure, Moco-chan?
Yeah, they have like water and juice in them, right?
Cactus juice.
Yeah, I guess, but you need to eat around the spikes too, right?
Well, maybe that's not something for me or the ruffians that we could do, but maybe Pero could.
Probably.
But, you know, he might look a bit silly afterwards, like a big pinkish... I guess I can see him doing it too, yeah.
He does look a little bit hydrated here, though.
He looks hydrated?
Dehydrated, dehydrated.
He's not looking great.
No, if he was looking hydrated, he'd look a little bit more blue.
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians!
In case you didn't know... Tomorrow!
Tomorrow is the big day of the hololive Minecraft Sports Festival!
This is our first time ever participating in something like this.
We're really excited to be a part of the red team!
And all of Abbot will be participating too.
Adventrix are in luck as well.
But for our team, it's just us and Biboo participating.
The advent on the red team.
We'll be participating in the Four Seasons Relay.
One game called Escort the Princess, and also Shoulder Voice.
I guess Shoulder Voice, the relay is a relay, right?
But Shoulder Voice is a game where we become Calli-senpai's horse, and she has to kill the other team members.
We don't have to do the killing, that's nice.
We just do the walking.
We're the legs.
We'll do our best, not as Demon Guard Dogs this time, but as Guard Horses.
How does a horse BAU BAU?
Is that a horse?
Is that the sound a horse makes?
I guess.
But we are also suddenly added to participate in this year's longest and most intense game, the Escort the Princess.
Regulus' Kanade was going to be one of the knights to protect Towa-senpai for our Red Team.
But Kanade's internet was lagging, so we were added instead.
Yeah, just sudden change, but I'm nervous!
Ruffians!
We'll be protecting Towa-senpai together with Shion-senpai and Ao!
Yeah, hopefully we'll be a good night, but... We'll do our best to be a good night.
I mean, guiding.
Yeah.
We should be good at that, right?
Well, there's a bunch of different segments involved in this one game, so we're nervous, but we're going to make sure that we practice and do our absolute best for Kanade-M so that the red team can win, too.
We know that Kanade was probably really looking forward to it, so it's too bad.
We'll do our best so that there's no regrets.
For both us and for Kaname.
I know maybe some Ruffians who joined us may be a little concerned that FUWAMOCO's a little bit quiet.
Because we just had a practice just before.
The pre-party.
Yeah, there was a lot of things going on.
A lot of senpai.
We're just trying to make sure to listen to Mikocchi-senpai, to Towa-senpai, so that we can get all the information and know what we're doing.
And then be able to translate that to all the other members that maybe don't know Japanese.
BAU BAU!
In case you didn't notice, there's also something to do with the sports festival.
In celebration of the sports festival, we participated in a new voice pack, the Sports Day Voice Pack!
This time we participated in English, but you can check them out over on the official hololive store.
I guess there's also 1 Minute Samples on the webshop as well.
I think it's a new addition, right?
So you can take a listen to it as well!
Same with all the voice packs too.
You can check out the samples that are included now.
But this is our first sports day ever!
So we had to do our best to- Ever, ever.
Ever, ever.
So we did our best to remember all the sports days we've seen in anime while we recorded it.
Yeah.
Did you like them?
Our voice packs.
We hope you liked them!
Why?
You know, it was a little bit tricky because we don't have much sports day experience.
No, I wonder why.
You liked them!
Why?
Sporty FUWAMOCO.
Why sporty?
We kind of saw a bit of your reactions on Twitter.
Seems like you really liked it.
The reaction was large.
Yeah, from the Ruffians that got their paws on it, I was seeing a lot of things.
We're really happy that you enjoyed it.
But the reaction is so large, we're kind of surprised.
You really just enjoy Sports Day a lot.
Maybe.
I don't know, we're really glad though!
We're really happy you liked them!
We're just surprised.
If you enjoyed this one though, we hope that you'll continue to check out our future voice packs too!
Yeah, we really enjoyed them so we hope that you will too.
BAU BAU!
Mococo Chieri!
Can you give us a bit of a sample of your Chieri?
Toss.
Toss!
Toss it like a boss!
Was that it?
Moco-chan, maybe you need to practice more if you can't remember it anymore.
A bit different.
BAU BAU!
I was really hoping that maybe today we could continue
I streaked for once.
Are you saying that I ruined it?
Yeah.
I ruined it!
There's been another misunderstanding, Ruffians.
I'm sure you realize what it is.
Was.
Was and is.
So, Ruffians.
Yesterday there was a misunderstanding.
And I thought I squashed it right there and then.
But, obviously, some of you didn't understand.
Solid!
I'll make it so you understand again, okay?
Yesterday, after my one day, we were asking, you know, if we should read the Super Chats now, or if we should try to get a bit of sleep before the Minecraft Sports Day pre-party that we just had, you know.
Yeah, because we were kind of planning to not get any sleep.
Yeah.
But...
So, I asked in just a simple poll.
And it was just easy.
We were talking about it.
So, considering the context of what we were discussing, if you had used your brain, it should have been okay!
What I asked was, Super Chat when?
And the answers were, now, or, after Donkey Kong Country, slash, a separate stream.
Those were the options.
And you know regularly, from the context... From that context!
You should think, read Super Chats when.
Not, give Super Chats when.
Okay?
I'm not asking for a time for you to Super Chat.
That's for you to decide if and when you would like to.
Not for us, okay?
So, bye now.
You know Ruffians, that we're always super thankful.
And that's why we want to take our time to be able to read them.
But it's very difficult when we accidentally make our schedule crazy like this.
It was an accident.
To be honest!
We also have some very important recordings and meetings that we're trying to fit in between these next two days before the Rocket Room Party!
As well as do all the prep for that!
We're lucky if we get a few hours of sleep at this point.
It's a bit rough, Ruffian!
Just a bit rough!
You reap what you sow.
Yeah.
We did it to ourselves.
We're gonna do our best to make every moment count right now, okay?
But you decided.
Super chat reading after Donkey Kong crazy, okay?
But we are gonna do super chat reading.
Ruffians!
What?
What are you doing?
Ruffians!
Why are you stopping, Shiori?
You make more misunderstandings.
You make more misunderstandings for me!
You understand, right?
You understand, right, Ruffians?
Because I'm concerned that you don't understand yet.
We're reading Super Chats after the Rocket Roof Party and after Donkey Kong Country.
I don't know if it'll be Donkey Kong Country or Super Stream, but we'll see.
Alright!
Okay!
Go for it!
Ruffians!
We're not demanding!
Not demanding!
Ruffians!
Ruffians, you're gonna make Moco-chan cry.
Huh?
No misunderstandings, okay?
She's just gonna continue making this annoying voice.
Don't do it to me like that, okay?
Morning!
You understand, right?
You're just being silly now.
Stop it.
Stop it?
Stop it!
Now you wanted a story, huh?
You wanted a story, huh?
Ruffians!
You know there was a bit of a story that we were telling back during our collab, our Family Feud collab with our IA-senpai.
You wanted to hear more about it, but you forgot.
You were a little bit shocked, I think.
Just a bit.
You still don't know, right?
Did you want to maybe know the full story?
There's really not much to it, but it's happy.
Sweater.
Very scary.
It's an easy story.
One day, you know, in the Northwest Passage, we are just kind of walking around the town squid, having a good afternoon.
This is 100% a true story, okay?
Percent.
Okay.
Moco-chan, you typo in your speech.
Don't say that!
What am I saying wrong?
Percent.
Huh?
You said percent.
A hundred percent.
Isn't that how you say it?
No, it's hundred percent.
Percent, not present.
100%!
That's how I've always said it!
Anyways!
It was a nice afternoon, and then suddenly, from right in front of us and out of nowhere, a grizzly bear started running towards us like a bullseye.
And you know, it's our amazing survival instincts.
You know what we did?
Biboo just stopped.
Stopped?
Yeah.
And then the bear just ran right past us.
You know, at the moment we didn't really think too much of it, but when we saw him running at us, we just thought, wow!
He's so close and big and fluffy!
If we just outstretched our hands, we could pet him, right?
That's a good fluffy density.
Yeah, it was cute.
Yeah, it was really cute.
And then, shortly after, we could hear some Demon Police dogs like BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And running right after the bear saying that, Get out of the way!
It's dangerous!
It's dangerous and that's kind of when we realized, Oh!
I guess that was dangerous.
I guess that wasn't good, huh?
That could have been our end just there.
Yeah, just another day in Northwood Passage, okay?
Remember, Ruffians,
Don't feed the wildlife, no matter how cute.
He was probably lost because he was eating food.
But we aren't wildlife though, so it's okay to feed us.
Yeah!
Got it!
We were just interested in his fur.
Yeah.
He looked fluffy.
Fun to ride, you know?
Fun to ride!
I was just gonna say that.
Right!
It was a simple story, nothing big.
Just a big, very scary bear.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I had a dream!
And I remembered it too!
Are you ready?
You better be ready!
It's my first dream, so... I'm gonna tell you it!
My first dream that I can share with the Ruffians.
It started with me noticing a big, big, black, fluffy spider on the wall.
It was kind of like a faraway wall, distant wall.
And it was like, it was okay.
I felt kind of like, oh, I sure hope that he's not gonna come over here.
And of course, you know, as soon as you hope that, it starts moving really fast.
And I climbed down from the wall and started doing backflips while moving closer and closer.
And like, rolling.
How?
Rolling?
Not rolling.
It was like, BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Yeah.
Just like any old spider.
Okay.
Fine.
Yeah, but I was doing it while getting closer and closer.
And then Moco-chan, you know Moco-chan, you were sitting down at a table and eating dinner or something.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I was like, Moco-chan, watch out!
There's a big spider!
And you were just like, okay, it won't bother me.
I'm just gonna sit here.
It's fine.
That's not like me at all.
And...
You just sat there, and it continued to dance around randomly and flip around.
I was like, oh no, this isn't gonna go well.
And of course, right after, it then flips onto the table and jumps onto Moco-chan's shoulder.
And of course, you just kind of freeze.
And so I just left there like, oh my goodness.
And Moco-chan, you're like, what the heck?
And then I just watched it slowly climb down your shoulder and back.
Slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
And Ruffians!
You know how Moco-chan's jacket is kind of short, right?
It's kind of short.
And your shirt is even shorter, right?
Yeah.
So I had to watch as then the spider slowly, leg by fluffy leg, walked over Moco-chan's back.
I got goosebumps.
And then you know,
Down onto the back of your shorts.
You know, like you transition from your skin to the shorts.
And like, you know how it's kind of like that area there?
What?
There's kind of like a bit of a gap between your back and the shorts.
Are you saying it went into my shorts?
No, but it was kind of close.
Yeah, like the soft area.
What?
Yeah, it was really unsettling.
Its legs were very hairy.
Yeah, and then I woke up.
I wonder what it means?
Detailed!
No, that's how Fuwawa's stories always go for her dreams.
Her flags were so hairy, but it was really hard to watch.
I could feel how itchy and gross it would be, like, being Moco-chan just sitting there, you know?
What was I eating?
It shouldn't be you!
It should have been, maybe.
What?
What were you eating?
I don't know!
Listen to me.
You might not have been eating anything.
Oh, I'm just sitting at the table eating nothing.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Hi.
And that was my dream.
Why was I sitting at a table?
I don't know.
You were just doing that.
We don't even have a table.
That was my dream.
BAU BAU!
Found something also kind of happy.
We found something new that we really really like.
It was sort of funny.
The other day we decided to try a new tea out to do with Monseo.
It's a special cinnamon orange tea, but it's super fancy.
It was on sale, so it's okay.
But when we opened it, we thought that it would be loose leaf tea.
But no!
It's just sort of packaged funny, but it's still in tea bags.
But we have to store it in the freezer apparently.
So we listen and we put it in the freezer.
But it really smells so good.
For some reason there's a really yummy cinnamon oil stuck to the inside of the packaging.
Do you like it?
It's like super strong and sweet, and it kind of feels like your tongue is on fire in a good way.
Yeah, it's not spicy, it's just sort of like pitter-pattering.
Yeah, I think I actually like it better than the tea.
Oh, the oil?
Yeah, it's really strong.
Oh, but the tea is super yummy too, it makes us feel sort of fancy.
Yeah, tea is wonderful.
It has all these instructions.
We're gonna drink this tea.
Lots!
That's what I think.
Yeah, yeah!
It's nice.
Very warming.
Maybe not so much Rat King tea?
No, you can't Rat King this tea.
No, you can't.
There's no tails.
No.
It's very important to the Rat King tea to have tails, okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Wow, let's head over to our regular corner again.
Our Doggie of the Day, we have... De-den!
It's Mookie!
Mookie is the Doggie of the Day!
I love Mookie's eyes.
Sock.
It's the same.
Mookie is so cute!
Same piece.
Well, you know, we're really happy to have such a cute viewer supporting us and enjoying their breakfast.
Right.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know, Mugi, looks like they might have been waking up a bit early this day, though, huh?
Maybe.
I get it.
Are you gonna go back to bed once you get your breakfast?
If you do, get a good rest, okay, Mugi?
Rest those eyes.
Yeah.
How does Mugi BAU BAU?
I feel like it's more like a... Maybe a tiny BAU BAU.
A bit husky but quiet.
Well, Mugi, Mugi is a character.
I think Mugi's very happy to share breakfast together with you while enjoying FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's always nice to share.
What more can you really ask for though, you know?
I think that is the sign of a true buddy.
Good buddy.
BAU BAU!
And next we have... Today I went on a walk
Why don't we go on a walk for this time?
De-den!
A nice foresty walk!
It looks so quiet.
It's just nice.
Peaceful.
You know we always do some very strong pondering sort of, what's the word?
Reflecting!
When we go on good walks like this.
You're pondering, we're pondering.
Both pondering.
This sky is so nice and blue here too.
The brown and the yellow and the green and the red.
To think though, just a few weeks ago those trees were filled with leaves and now you know before you know it, there'll be snow covering all of them.
The years passed by just so fast.
So fast.
But please, Ruffians, make sure you dress warmly so you don't catch a cold, okay?
Yeah, especially when you go somewhere like a bit more forest area.
One day you might go outside and be like, oh, it's warm!
But the next day it might be very cold, so be careful, okay?
BAU BAU!
And our question of the day!
Let's see!
De-den!
This may be a very silly question, but why is ear and tail touching a no-go if you don't even bat an eye to paw holding?
Bat an eye to paw holding?
What makes you think that we don't bat an eye to paw holding?
Huh?
You know, we're fine together because it's safer that way if something's scary or if we need to cross a busy road, so it's okay.
But I don't think we've ever done anything to say otherwise.
You know, paw holding should be with someone you love and care about.
Like your family and friends.
Simple answer.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions.
We're always looking for new questions.
Doggie of the Day, you know.
Pero Sightings, too.
But for our next stream!
It's time for us to do our best to communicate with each other and do our best also to disarm the bombs because we're playing keep talking and nobody explodes.
I think we're real good.
I don't know.
I think Ruffians
If you know a little bit about us, our communication skills can be a little interesting, right?
We don't need to talk, it'll be okay.
I don't know, I think... Exactly!
Either we'll do really well, or really poorly.
Which one do you think, Ruffians?
Well or poor?
Well, you'll have to be there to find out!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Well, after the hololive sports festival, we have our FWMC Rock n' Rawr Party!
But this time the theme is hardcore!
BAU BAU!
We're going to be singing lots of songs that include lots of voice, and lots of rock, and a couple of BAU BAUs here and there too.
It will probably include some BAU BAUs, you know how things are.
We hope that your markers will be able to keep up with us, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today, Ruffians!
We're gonna do our best next with practice for the sports festival.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Nanjiro Nagayon.
BAU BAU!
Mr. Lick.
Kitsuneko.
BAU BAU!
Gwen.
Ex-Human Boy.
BAU BAU!
Dreaming Noisagi.
Yellow.
BAU BAU!
Maid of the Soup.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!